[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia para hablar sobre
algunos mitos y verdades de los síntomas
de el coronavirus doctor pérez gracias
por acompañarnos buenos días empiezo
preguntándole el de las personas con
enfermedades autoinmunes que se podrían
vacunar contra el kobe 19 primero
teniendo en cuenta que algunas
enfermedades no permiten que los
pacientes se puedan vacunar
raúl hay que tener en cuenta que las
vacunas son primero algo muy seguro y
que la gran inmensa y la mayoría de la
mañana del 2 de iu las pueden usar sin
problemas de lo que sabemos ahora es que
estas vacunas que están en desarrollo
están en pruebas en diferentes grupos
humanos incluidos personas que tienen
enfermedades autoinmunes personas que
tenga alteraciones en las defensas
sabemos que las vacunas de virus vivos
no se pueden aplicar en enfermedades
autoinmunes
pero las vacunas que están actualmente
en desarrollo ninguna contiene virus
vivos de coronavirus entonces muy
probablemente las vacunas que se
desarrollan para coronar al virus se van
a poder usar universalmente es decir en
todas las personas independientemente en
la patología ahora doctor hablemos de
otro tema también que le preocupa a
muchas personas como diferenciar la
pérdida del olfato y el gusto que deja
el coronavirus con los síntomas a lo
mejor de una gripe normal donde ocurre
lo mismo
es mucho más frecuente que cuando haya
pérdida del olfato y del gusto sea por
coronarios que pronto es fría o común
por eso si presentamos estos síntomas es
necesario consultar al médico primero no
asustarse en la mayoría de personas que
tiene alteración del gusto del olfato no
desarrollo en la enfermedad más compleja
esto es reversible es decir que con el
pasar del tiempo puede pasar y se puede
revertir retomar el gusto y el olfato
sin ningún problema el resfriado común
también lo produce pero en muy poco
tiempo es cuestión de semanas de pocos
días en el colon agroexpo durar un mes
dos meses este retorno a la normalidad
del gusto y del olfato pero se va a
recuperar entonces tranquilidad se puede
presentar en cualquier infección
respiratoria y en la mayoría de peces va
a ser del ciclo ahora doctor si hay
alguna infección se pierde esta
inmunidad digamos que significa en este
contexto la reinfección y lo decimos
además por las últimas noticias de tres
pacientes que han se han reinsertado
es usual que entre los virus
respiratorios haya lo que suceda una
reflexión es decir que no nos vuelve a
dar gripa no era de extrañar que los
coronarios nos vuelvan a dar y lo que se
ha demostrado es que en una muy pequeña
en la fracción muy pequeña de la
población puede haber la infección está
la infección puede suceder cuatro o
cinco meses después de recuperarse de
coito generalmente por otra cepa de
virus pero la característica es que es
mucho menos agresiva incluso en estos
pacientes será totalmente asintomáticos
qué implicaciones tienen primero que
tenemos que seguir el autocuidado así
seamos recuperados de kobe y seguramente
es que la vacunación va a ser una
vacunación no una vez en la vida sino
probablemente sea anual semestral o
bianual es decir van a ser varias dosis
repetidas para tener control del corona
de los por parte de nuestro sistema
inmunológico doctor se viene ahora en la
región de américa latina más desescalada
de los confinamientos en el momento
crítico que estamos viviendo entre los
casos en aumento y también en los
decesos le preguntó si va hasta entonces
sólo con el tapabocas
humanos y distanciamiento social para
cuidarnos
y estos tres elementos son fundamentales
pero aquí el más importante es la
disciplina humana en estos momentos de
desconfía miento ya la responsabilidad
no es de las autoridades la
responsabilidad no son de los decretos
de las ordenanzas sino de una
responsabilidad que nos cabe a nosotros
mismos como seres sociales responsables
cuidadores de nuestra salud de nuestras
familias y de nuestro entorno el gran
problema es que debe mantenerse lo que
más se pueda el aislamiento físico por
ejemplo y teletrabajo pero muchas
personas han dicho no es que el
teletrabajo no es verdadero trabajo es
mejor que vuelvan a las oficinas si un
empresario sabe que el teletrabajo le
está funcionando manténgalo así es
necesario que nosotros sigamos con las
políticas que han sido exitosas para que
no se infecte la gente la medida de
confinamiento ayudan a la reactivación
económica pero solamente la disciplina
de nosotros ayuda a que con tengamos el
virus
doctor muchísimas gracias entonces por
todo lo que nos ha dicho con respecto a
este cover de 19 gracias por estar con
nosotros en esta sección de 5 minutos
con el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia doctor feliz resto
de día a ustedes también continué con
nosotros
[Música]